fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre la fiche a
été collé le 14 mars la presse dominique
pedrina s'y préparent la réouverture de
sa boutique de vêtements devrait se
faire le 12 mai avec dès l'entrée lavage
obligatoire des mains au gel pas plus de
deux clients à la fois respect de la
distanciation des règles de base plus
quelques autres le nombre de vêtements
essayé sera limité ensuite les vêtements
essayé sera stockée sur un pourtant il y
restera environ 2 à 3 heures et après
avec une sphère a enfin fer à vapeur
avec une pression suffisante passé sur
le vêtement ou pour désinfecter des
conseils que dominique pedrina a trouvé
sur un réseau d'entre elles de
commerçants je fais partie d'un groupe
d'entr'aide sur facebook
donc on communique beaucoup les
boutiques dans l'hexagone et donc on a
toutes le même le même sentiment quoi
envie d'ouvrir mais une inquiétude
hervé châtoire ouvert son magasin
d'optique il ya une semaine seulement
sur rendez-vous pour livrer des lunettes
commander ou renouveler des lentilles de
contact mais la vente va reprendre avec
des procédures qui iront bien au delà
des gestes barrières de prêt - je pense
un petit peu comme ça car il est plutôt
sur plateau choisir quelques paires de
lunettes et le client et ses yeux quatre
cinq six planètes maximum puisque après
trois tours et décontaminer donc c'est
pour la sécurité des clients et pour
pronostiquer pour les essais s'approcher
de la personne la personne prendre
lunettes elle essaye elle même et puis
hervé château rendra le port du masque
obligatoire pour tous
une décision qui sera à la discrétion de
chaque commerçant incitations plutôt
qu'aux obligations
cette réouverture des petits commerces
sera scrutée de près elle conditionnera
la suite du déconfinement